okay okay everyone see my screen okay
great all right so I'm gonna start with
datoria
which is caught encrypt the computation
with atlases so they sort of silly a a
are named from at any weeks but let me
start with a circle motivation about why
we're looking at all this one reason why
we're looking at all this not about
cryptographic instructions so we now
live in this world big data where we
clear love sensitive data what
individuals are financial medical
customer employee and so and so forth
and one of the concerns is the it's a
privacy of this data where disapper
sensitive data and traditional could do
wisdom says that if you want to put that
privacy of all data we can basically
encrypt this data
so what encryption essentially does is
that it books the data in a in a box and
be supposed to lock on it so the only
whoever has the key will be able to
access this data now the problem is that
well now once this data is encrypted we
lose utility without the key will no
longer be able to encrypt this data so
what what we'll be talking about in some
of this new cryptographic construction
is a new way of looking at things
this new paradigm which we referred to
informally as encrypted computation also
sometimes known as computing but cooler
we'll be looking at today across today's
talks at three different notions of
computing encrypted data and I was
interesting over here is that over the
show that all this tree notions can be
realized from that assumptions and now
moreover basically from one single
equation so I try to be first set of
what this equation is and some of these
are primitives in the constructions
alright so when do I become the boss of
this probably the one of the most famous
one in that sense they are fully
homomorphic encryption so before I
define fully homomorphic encryption we
first just remind you what our
encryption is so in the content of this
talk we'll be looking at or in the
continuity construction we'll be looking
at encryption the secret key setting
super encryption algorithm and
decryption world and what don't share a
secret key basic functionality says that
if I include a value X and I decrypt to
get what we call set attacks
and who decrypt the subtext after the
secret key recovery ultra print xxxx
basically says that the encryption X
should have active no she is Ricky Roma
this is the secret key setting so we
really actually do require that even
many different values at the same secret
key X all the side protection also hi
all this ocean of plaintext values so
the main difference between in some
sense fully homomorphic encryption
traditional encryption is the additional
functionality requirement which says
that as they say evolution algorithm or
evaluation procedure that this is
importing from X and any function f
produces an encryption type of X so the
big picture in cryptography I guess a
decade ago now it's basically that we
can actually be a fully home encryption
for the cause of all circuits from our
lattice assumptions so what I first
introduced this idea in undergraduate
crypto class II in France everyone
staring at me funny like why is this
even a big deal so officially very much
in some sense it's like you know the
Internet so for us for both of us who
were born before the view of the
information at this big thing for all of
you like born in the 90s this is like
something always taken for granted so
let me just say that it's actually a
very or so the only works are show how
to construct this from that assumptions
this first cat by creature entry the
other doors after where she showed no
not only can we construct from that
assumption we can actually get it from
what's called out of your assumptions
which will basically be a recurring
assumption in in this workshop so what
the other big assumption basically says
that if I give you a random matrix P
think of it as very wide and as some
speed plus noise this be together x
times B that's nice to explain them
so basically noise is what we copy think
over SMBs uniformly random from some
matrices and vectors from whose entries
are drawn from some underlying reading
like that q and e you think of as small
trees
so this basically says that Gaussian
elimination with noise is hot
so right so one of the constructions
today will be based on yourself every
assumption okay okay in particular will
be I'll be describing the construction
based are by argentarius at high waters
sorry
checking to see what the blinking screen
says right I'll be talking about I'll be
presenting this construction by your
ejector ISA hi worthless okay
all right so all right trying to see
what the construction is it's the warm
up first we're going to basically first
show how to be a form of encryption if I
were leading to another security so with
the first view my encryption scheme is
fully homomorphic but insecure now
that's a simple way to do this you don't
even need to encode the message of X is
just X the main difference between this
insecure scheme that will describe and
the the main advantage of it is that it
has more added distance when actual
secure scheme so bear with me I'm going
to describe a scheme that in some sense
needlessly complicated its own type of
security but nice thing is that would be
minor tweak you can actually go to
Kyousuke alright so what if the scheme
look like the secret key is a vector a
row vector whose entries are uniformly
random from that Q which is our
underlying ring so this row vector we
call T the cipher text is going to be
square matrix right so encryption is a
square matrix a with the property that
key times a is equals to x times 3 so
high school in the algebra stage that we
refer to t as basically eigenvector for
a with eigenvalue x we wouldn't really
be needing this notion of eigen vector
but we need the equation x equals x
times T ok so this is basically what our
subjects would look like alright so what
we need to do to get this a fully
homomorphic encryption is that when you
give some people should procedure that
you know given encryptions produces f of
X so basically a sufficient to
essentially focus to handle general
circuits it's efficient to focus on how
the kind
and multiplication so we think of
instead of being encrypted one value we
think of as being being encrypted many
veterans think of access are scalars or
bits so you want a way to keep an
encryption of X 1 and X 2 produce
encryption X 1 plus X 2 and also to
produce encryption x1 times x2 so we've
talked to a I as an encryption exit I
okay so addition turns out to be very
easy if you have two matrices a1 and a2
oh such a T times a1 x1 times T and T
times a 2 X 2 times T if you add the 2
matrix up together you actually get a
new matrix such a key times this new
matrix is exactly x1 plus x2 times T so
this sort of satisfy so a1 does it will
indeed in some sense of a little
encryption x1 plus x2 so ignoring
distribution in your comments for now
let's just try to satisfy this this
credit equation alright now how do we
then get to given a 1 a 2 how do we get
a new matrix such a tea cup this new
matrix is x1 times actual times T well
basically web 2 square matrices what can
you do to them we already show that you
can add them the next answer I think we
do is to try to multiply them they
straightforward to check that if in
particular 3 times a 1 times a 2 is in
the x1 times x2 times T so the proof is
straightforward you basically we place
it on some a 1 by X 1 times T then T my
x2 you actually and then you get one
person or a head side okay if I by
straightforward induction this gives
real want to any put it on them all
right so for example if you want to get
an encryption about x1 times x2 plus x3
x4 you basically just multiply a 1 by a
2 plus a 3 times in fact the skills of
any point on me this is what I would you
like to would you like to address the
question you see the Q&A no actually
don't get the Q&A window sorry I want to
figure out how to uh so so there's a
question in the Q&A window until then
let me repeat that for you how is
encryption of secret key comma X defined
Oh encryption of secret key common
testifying good that's a good question
all right
but now think of right what's the in
something was a distribution so the
output of a crucian of T comma X is a
matrix a such a T times X times T so so
in sum I have a sick of this
distribution for T is I think of it as
picking random you random you mean
probably matrix a such a T times a
equals x I'm sleep now
okay so pick a uniformly random a to
satisfy this equation questions ok I
can't figure out how to show the Q&A we
know at same time so it's require you
may have to repeat the questions to me
alright so the nice thing about this is
that excuse of any polynomial in fact
you know if I when you point me at and
variables T terms F of a 1 to a n is
exactly in some sense encryption
now how do you even apply a polynomial
to matrices
I think of the knife which is basically
you know the generation of this just
replace each of the variables with other
corresponding matrices now the little
boy started be here in a sense that
makes response creation is not
commutative but let's just fix I'm
ordering let's say always multiply in
the lexicographic order and then it
gives you a way to multiply apply point
on mental matrices in fact it doesn't
really matter how you are handling
multiplication multiplication whether
you do a 1 comes a 2 or a 2 times a 1
you still get a point on your such that
G times M is X 1 X 2 times T so that's a
natural way to define F applied to all
these matrices and that basically is
what official evaluation okay alright so
now let's try to fix this scheme so this
scheme is a satisfy function T by this
our security so let's try to fix this
scheme so that you get security along
the way we're going to lose
functionality and then we try to fix it
now this sort of goes back to the
earlier question the question from Q&A
if you care about security is actually
very important
exactly precisely say what is
distribution of encryption of xkx all
right but let's just say for now that
took a security basically what would add
noise the intuition is that if you know
how to see the previous scheme is
complete we'll come back option
liberation and the intuition from the
out of your assumption is that if you
add noise then you can get a secure
scheme okay so this roughly what go and
do we're gonna say precisely how to
carry out this distribution later but
basically now an increment X is no
longer going to be a matrix after three
times a is exactly X items T it's gonna
be case and T times X is close to X
items T all right what does closed mean
closed you should think of as sort of
closed in our in I guess L infinity norm
so a difference of the two of them is
small Baptist chuckles entries is small
or you can think of closest being a
difference being that nice distribution
without every assumption any more
questions okay so intuitively this is
distribution that we're going to be
looking at will say a bit precisely what
the situation is going to be but turned
out basically if you add noise then you
can show that basically given a I or
many a I should learn nothing about the
underlying action so this gives you
security let's try to see whether what
happens of functionality all right so at
least for addition things to work now if
you're given two matrix such that T
times a 1 of course 1 times T and T
times a 2 is closed x2 times T then 3
times a1 plus a2 is too close to X 1
plus X 2 times T basically this is
because when you add two small values to
get small value now the new small value
you get is going to be slightly bigger
than the previous small values but let's
ignore this distinction from now or
smaller this moment they're different oh
sure of small but let's just stick them
at all so much pain smart enough we'll
come back to this a bit later let's see
what happens when you do multiplication
right turns out if you try to nicely
proceed as before if you just multiply a
1 times a 2 then T times a 1 times a 2
is actually not going to be close
actually comes tea and the reason
basically is that the the small from tea
time to a one gets multiplying to a to
think of a to a uniformly random matrix
so each of these entries is uniformly
random from its at Q and in general
uniformly random for Ella mushrooms that
you are going to be big so a2 is
basically gonna be big so when you
multiply small by bigger one gets peak
value so you don't quite get our
correctness anymore you can do if you
had the addition but you don't you
cannot handle multiplication so here's
why the next idea comes in we're going
to make a ice wall now think of a is
itself a uniformly random matrix such
that we have a eyes-closed X n times T
it's going to be uniformly random
matrices more entries now at this point
it's not even exactly clear if such a a
as this but let's pretend for now that
such a is it you can send us more a I
such a cheat of small a ice close X eye
cups tea so we somehow manages and pass
that the a I have some more entries then
the previous problem goes away
now if you look at small x a2 a2 is now
small so now T times small x a2 is still
going to be small and that allows you to
argue that key times a1 x a2 is close to
actual X 2 times T ok so that sort of
solves our problem so now what what do
we end up with right now what we have
now
oh sorry this also since we already have
the additional modification for the same
results before the skills and importance
right so you can ensure that key times
are F of a while to a and is closed
right so why have I done so far but and
so far basically to give you a template
to build a fully homomorphic encryption
scheme or other stems they say and then
they say I need to come up to following
I need to come up a distribution for
Astrid keys which I wrote back the
street and you come up with random small
matrices a with the port with the
property that T x is cos x times T
that's the first basic requirement sort
of a generalization of the eigenvalue
eigenvector approach to this approximate
setting and we need two additional
properties we need the a high sex
this gives you security of the
encryption scheme and we need the a the
entries of a are small this gives you
the squishy home markup application so
if you can get all these free properties
from some reasonable assumption that
these assumptions then you get an
efficient scheme so we have reduced this
general problem to just satisfying these
three properties all right so all right
so how we're gonna go so I'm actually
gonna show you how to get all this free
I'll just set this part of the screw
covers against nothing fingers out of
your assumption and sort of like before
what were to try to sort of satisfy some
subset of the requirement is you make no
the other ones and try to fix it all
right so first we're gonna try to
satisfy the first requirement which is T
times any it's good x times T all right
so what does he look like now and he is
not going to be uniformly random vector
over that Q anymore it's going to
basically be the first half is going to
be unique on the random the final entry
is going to be minus one okay no diaper
s here that s basically is the
distribution of the secret estimate of
the reabsorption okay now our sample.txt
well try to build this came from our
debris assumption so we have to put in
out of the Assumption type challenges
somewhere so the ciphertext is going to
look sort of like the out of Weeki the
quantitation out to be assumption so
that's a go to B matrix P together with
s times B plus C okay remember that this
quantity this quantity over here by
service pseudo-random externalizes okay
now the secret T now note that if you
multiply the secret key as minus 1 by
this quantity you get something that's
small
now this is our secret key which going
to be T and once sort of are the ones
you're on the right-hand side I want x
times T on the right side what do I do
I basically exams I to this to this
quantity over here by linearity this
time this is small this times this T
times X I is basically substitute
okay so I've satisfied my basic
requirement which is that 3 times 8
close to x times T I'm going to call
this quantity over here my okay so
satisfy my first requirement in Fausto
satisfy my second requirement which is
that a high sex by the LW assumption
this thing looks human
and then uniform class exams I is
uniform so this holding with you
so I set this one a secular bomb but the
problem now is that you know this is my
a and I haven't I need to somehow make a
small by the way I'm doing I think
pretty well on time so questions alright
so I need to make this a small okay I
may have a question is that question I
see one yeah so so there's a question
whether X is a bit which ah good okay
yeah so early on when we talk about
that's a good question early on when we
talk about the basic eigenvectors acting
who knows no insecure scheme as can come
from that queue henceforth were
basically going to what with X being a
bit it hasn't quite come up yet but
let's just say that sufficient oh hang
the excess a bit there was an additional
question about the smallness of the
matrix a which I assume that you're
going to get to next so I do not bring
it up here so if the person who still
has the question after the end of the
slide it can bring it up again
okay and in general if you see that you
raise the question that's already been
answered and you know just try this
missus just so that we know that that
you're fine I'll try to uh suppose I was
so ever so often it's a question right
so this is our a all right before the
problem is that a is a actually has
large entries because you know this part
over here the B when they think about
the wave function should think I'd be is
coming from our using familiar you mean
from the rent as uniformly random
entries right so this is going to be big
we also want this to be pseudo-random so
this is so this whole thing is big so a
now is big entries now we want to make a
turn a into a matrix a small entries and
do something more general what going to
earth so that snakes we're going to show
how to make a small ignore for a moment
how to get a 2x now I don't make a small
in fact we're going to give a generic
transformation that takes any matrix
over that Q and turn it into a matrix of
no entries in fact we're going to give
you a generic major transformation that
takes any matrix M any arbitrary
dimensions can be right
can be square can be vectors can be
whatever you want and turn it into a
matrix more entries how small the
entries you are going to be actually
Israel one so how do you get to
something where entries are from Zack
you to something is your one you
basically want to take the binary
representation of okay let me see if we
cut is caught Vikki composition so I'll
take the binary representation of matrix
what does it even mean to take the
binary representation of a matrix so
first I'm going to take okay so
basically while going to happen is that
this new matrix of order to get it's
going to be it has much bigger
dimensions the height is going to be
locked two times the dimension of the
original matrix I think the top part
it's going to be stacked in a specific
way the top of this new matrix is the
recent commit of the matrix M what is
the reason for coming bit of a matrix
it's basically they're listening to
compete on every entry of the matrix
entry wise mystic embeds the bottom of a
matrix is going to be most difficult of
the matrix what does that mean entry
wise most so the second block is going
to be the second bit and then the third
bit of pop it right out the most
goodness and so in general this thing is
going to be basically the the matrix on
the right is going to be low look like
basically lock two blocks of mate
research each block has the same
dimensions origin matrix the first block
the topmost block is the little bit of
the entry okay this is a this gives you
a generic way to to take any matrix and
turn it into a matrix row 1 entries that
in some sign contains the same
information right now in general this
transformation is actually not going to
be lenient taking bits computing bits of
a of a number is essentially not a
linear operation but what it's nice
however is that the inverse of this
computation should be a linear
computation in particular if I have this
sort of this binary representation for
matrix M I can recover the ocean of
matrix M by left multiplying this matrix
by another matrix ok so this is a linear
operation that goes from this matrix to
the original matrix over here now what
is this matrix that you need to multiply
by and you multiply by very white matrix
the dimension
and what are the entries of this matrix
the first half the puss is going to be
sort of blocks of matrices the first
block is going to be I 2 times I four
times I up to Q over 2 times time okay
what happens when you multiply this
matrix by this you basically get a list
you can't becomes I the second bit comes
to the top becomes 4 and the most one
becomes Q over 2 and that basically
exactly is you
you're basically x out of two and you
get back to our matrix okay so what's
nice here is that even though going from
this representation this representation
of linear you can from you can go back
by a linear transformation right so this
is actually just matrix multiplication
we're going to call this G which is
first complicate gadget matrix in the
reflection and because this times G is
this matrix over here Pauline is ritual
I'll go and denote this matrix over here
but G inverse okay let me stress that G
inverse of M is not the matrix inverse
of G multiplied by M whether you should
think of it as this binary
representation you should know G inverse
as a function applied to the matrix then
record reimbursed because G times this
thing gives you any questions is that a
real question or I see a 1 on top of the
queue entity should try to figure out ok
so let me carry on for now so yeah so
maybe maybe I'll read the question the
question is do we need this
transformation because there's no L
ability for small a it's a very good
question
all right ok the the question is good
the the transformation is actually good
basically we want we want something to
be small right so if you look at this
thing over here maybe out of the holes
even be conscious more entries but you
need this SB + e to the random so
there's no way SP + es could look random
if it's going to be small
okay so roughly speaking you need this
transformation to get to get to
something that small in fact roughly
speaking if you want to prove out double
e for if you want to prove that out of
if for small B follows from reading from
the random video actually going to apply
this transformation all right
so sorry so now we have this
transformation I'm going to apply this
tree inverse operation to our to our
matrix over here
so let's apply G inverse to this thing
and this gives you a way to make sure
that my is so I still want to maintain
this quantity over here so if I apply
dreamville to this quantity I need to
multiply feedback so if I do if I put
energy energy inverse I still meet in
the same equation and now this G inverse
will and post all these entries are
small so this is going to be the G
inverse of whatever you see our a will
be on you a and now we guarantee the age
okay but now we have a new problem which
is that this is our T that some G over
here and the some there's a T on the
right-hand side and this gene is to
somehow you know disappear so turn out
the right thing to do is that I can
replace this I by G and then I get T G
on the right hand side so to replace I
by G I becomes wider
so you actually need the B to be much
wider but that's fine out of these two
schools so now you have teach you in the
left hand side and teach you on the
right hand side you just caught teach
you a new key so now we set this for
everything so our new key will basically
be s minus 1 times G this will be our a
ok and this satisfy the equation this
time this is x times T we get that a has
X because by the out of your assumption
this is uniformly random when you
applied reimburse it doesn't think any
more information and we have to a small
because G will select this quantity over
okay so this is basically I won't find a
fishy scheme
you questions okay so basically I've
shown you how to view a victory scheme
let me just take a quick detour to talk
about this issue or small I'm gonna try
to make this a bit quick it's sort of
talking into the rest of the tutorial
and so I talked about you know how small
values are small and that they're
different notions of small so in general
uh you know what will happen is that if
we actually multiply two matrices
together for homo multiplication we
actually end up multiplying bacteria
must practice something x dream post one
to go with something else now in general
dreamer subtract anything is good have
entries are zero one when you multiply
two entries two matrices a zero one you
actually get something that's a little
bit bigger it actually grows by
basically the dimension of the matrix so
if you do math equation this way naively
when you define a small that you get
from your after you apply a point emir
of degree F if your new small it's going
to grow exponentially right
okay just quickly backtrack why do we
care about the how quickly small girls
because basically the how small the
final value is going to be well
basically affect how big the modulus is
going to be for correctness and this in
terms effect the basically the the kind
of assumptions we need to make for other
cookie we basically want small noise
prove to get in some sense
quantitatively weaker assumptions so if
you do things this way it will grow with
degree of acquisition sort of the world
for a while and what you want to do
really is basically to instead of
applying G inverse to m1 times m2 and
everyone to multiply two things together
you basically apply the G but after you
do the modification
so you apply the gene was M to first
multiply m1 by this and then do Jimbo's
at the very end this ensures that the
final output will still be zero entries
note that both of these equations
satisfy the property that when you
multiply by G you get back the same
value and by sort of really ordering or
dreama's operations you can actually get
a nice view of that exponential and
logarithm of the degree and this says
have to be the right thing to do for
circuits so that you grow exponentially
if this is one idea to get some on the
nice chrome under just quickly also
mention a small a second idea to get
small noise group in the context of our
lattice paste crypto so the way I
describe the scheme so far when I talk
about polynomials well really basically
essentially working with aromatic
circuits for me can you go back one
slide
oh yeah sure
give me the you have time also okay so
what are you saying here how did you get
over the how did you get to this to the
logarithmic of power okay so I slightly
cheated but so what is the difference
between both both of this equation they
both satisfy the prop with G time the
whole thing is M 1 times G inverse of M
2 so if you do it this way all you do it
this way you still get em to the
difference is that if you do it this way
you get a product with your matrices
your new matrix is going to grow
basically the dimensions of the two
things whereas if you wait you about to
fly first then do your dream was the
upload this will always be your entries
so somehow your noise goes a little bit
slower in fact logarithm agree the exact
details doesn't follow quite from this
equation this noise and so on so forth
but is the basic idea you want to
reorder your dreams operations in a way
that helps you grow most oh okay all
right so that's the second idea that's
also used in each one elective speech
crypto which is basically why say so far
when you wrote homies you're basically
working with circuits the the thing
about circuits is basically that so well
actually working aromatic circuit so you
are going to be have this additional my
creation gates addition gets turned out
to be okay not a big problem
the main issue with this big nose groups
come over multiplication gates now what
all circuits what's basically going to
be happening is that a circuit has the
circuit model of computation the
property that you always essentially
multiply values from are two
intermediate computations and basically
this cause of phenomenon where basically
every time you do a math equation and
you have a math question key you
basically double the noise and this
creates a phenomenon where the the the
the noise is going to grow exponentially
in the death Tesla is much better to
work with branching programs the basic
property that we have a branching
program is basically a bunch of brands
of property that in each step of the
computation you always sort of I'll read
one input bit look at what the
intermediates that you are in an
impressible next step so what happens
when you translate this into the fhe
setting is that basically you never
multiply to equal
values you always multiply into my
intermediate value by an input value now
the input value you can guarantee that
noises fixes very small and now your
noise only multiplies to impart
interpret noise by the input noise so
it's just going a lot slower in general
happens when evolve branching programs
is that your noise will grow with the
length of the branch improvement now
recall that if you have a secure Locker
at the back then it can be simulated by
a branching program of polynomial length
now what this happens now is that if you
apply sort of the knife approach to work
with circuits you get a noise that got
expression in that so you can end the
order and blow up works if you walk the
punching program since the noise is
point over in the length you get a poly
n glow so that's really a vantage of
working on branching programs and this
is same phenomena actually that
underlies some of the more more recent
work on this function secret sharing
from deviation of action problems sort
of this exploiting this asymmetry in the
way we handle battery program
computation and this basically allows
you to get a PC for lock left circuits
with a polynomial blow up so you can
under point on your hand assumptions and
the same idea so what so now as I
described essentially two ideas the
Contra noise group one is to reorder the
tree inverse we are going to of
branching programs it's all circuits
okay so this that care for the small
values issue but okay so all this can
you just explain maybe for the larger
audience with Ponyville harness means
polynomial hotness means yeah use the
terms oh I see okay right so in general
right so the algebra assumption in
sometimes actually a interpreter
parametrize assumption so the hotness of
the other BRE assumption actually has a
parameter which is basically the ratio
of the the noise the ratio of the other
line modulus of the noise you want this
quantity to be as small as possible
basically the assumption is weaker if
the ratio is point on me and the
assumption is stronger if the ratio is
safe some estimation this sort of makes
sense because you know when the ratio is
big you're actually adding
very very small noise so our point of
mija this means that you're in the
regime when the ratio is point on and
the port number comes from the fact that
this very so basically the ratio that
you need basically comes from the blob
in the noise when you do your
computation so what perhaps since you've
been going on you've been going over
some pretty technical stuff if there's
additional questions from the panelists
or from the audience I see that there is
I guess one in the Q&A section asking if
there is a price that is that you're
paying for using branching programs like
why wouldn't you is it always better to
use branching programs in circuit good
okay good so remember that the branching
program is actually a weaker model
computation we convert a circuit to a
branching program you get a blow up as
explanation attack so so when you are
what would branching programs is
actually in something the weaklings the
most preciousness you can only handle
log that circuits but the nice thing is
that you get asked more than nice group
okay so a lot when you're ever you're
dealing with out that's the kids
expected the world matching programs but
not for bunching programs do not employ
resourceful circuits because the weaker
model computation
so perhaps can you say something if you
can always convert the computation into
a branching program are there cases
where you cannot do this right so in
general if you have a circuit you can
convert a branching program we hope the
waters exponential death so you know if
your circuit held that that's super
logger that mean you're branching
programs will have super portable size
so in that sense you know you can only
convert logarithm attacks in trees so
perhaps the participant would like to
know what you do when you do have
circuits with the sort of super long
super logarithmic that how do you do
homework evaluation so you basically
should stick to the original scheme when
you hander what you basically basically
you essentially convert a circuit into a
point Omiya and then just go one should
be a little bit careful what you mean by
converting a circuit to a point Omiya
but basically you do what you do it you
you look at the aromatic circuits
whenever must patient get you much
better set this together but I didn't
get you just at the matrixes to get or
so
so I make this detour into talking about
small this is something that we won't be
using for the rest of the talk I want to
go back to our original sort of a fishy
scheme and this Bureau I can't think is
eigenvectors so right so I'm coming back
to the small issue anymore if anybody
has questions about the small I know or
we can just take them to the end of the
talk let me come back to this again
vector issue so basically the the crux
of this are fully homomorphic encryption
scheme really boils down to what happens
before you introduce noise so the magic
of it is sort of this algebraic
phenomenon that says that if I have a
bunch of matrices and the vector P such
a T times a XXI times T then T times a
is f of x times T here where a F is a
shorthand for F applied to these
matrices a1 today instead of this this
simple algebraic identity sort of you
know follows from high school linear
algebra so that gives us all this magic
fhq relax the approximation value all
right so now I want to we already gave
one generalization this in some sense
where we go from exact equality to
approximate equality now I think about I
want to show you a different
generalization but before that let me
rewrite this equation as saying sort of
you know moving tourists from the right
hand side to the left hand side this
basically just says that T times y equal
0 implies these are the same thing and
this holds for any point right all right
now I want to analyze this thing in what
sense
so this is a statement about matrices a1
to a and share the same eigen vector T
I want a generalization to this
statement that does not talk about eigen
vectors I want a statement the
generalization of this statement applies
to any matrices a1 up to a wife is
useful it's useful let's just try to
generate this thing or what could this
statement potentially look like so
there's no T anymore so basically I want
to relate the terms on the left hand
side to the term on the right hand side
so on ref Esther
going to an a1 minus x1 x1 I wish
corresponds to mop - my hands have AF
minds fo for a 170 on the statement that
implies a statement that I call them I
do that implies level 1 okay so here's
the statement will tell you what the
statement is and I'm going and they will
commit ourselves at implies lemma 1 and
I'll show you how to prove lemma okay so
here's our new lemon - ok the new lemma
2 is going to say that if given a bunch
of matrixes and any X so I come to xn
and any function f in fact any poem
where f that as this sub matrix H this
matrix H is going to depend on by the
way the order of on the power goes is
going to be on the image is just X and F
such that H multiplied by the stuff over
here
it's equal to the right hand side this
is the adrenaline is the correct
generalization of lemma 1 let me first
convince you that lemma that lemma 2 is
indeed a generalization of lemma 1 so
let me first convince you that lemma 2
does implant proof well just multiply
both sides by G if you multiply both if
lemma do is I'm going to prove that
lemma to impress them I am NOT at this
moment I'm not proving that llama - it's
true
let me just do a sanity check the lemma
2 is in the generalization of lemma 1 so
they want to impress them r1y if you
multiply both sides by T and he comes
left hand side is going to be 0
thanks to this 0 comes a to 0 so the
right hand side is 0 so T times right
hand side 0 which is like this alright
let me pause for a moment and get
questions yeah there's a few questions
so the questions about the the sort of
branching program still the conversion
from service to branching programming
and when it's useful the first one is
whether it is whether you can do this
type of inversion also ok if I take all
punching program questions to the end of
the talk yeah so let's just do that yeah
yeah
also it's sort of mode of computation
and so the orthogonal axis okay so if
you guys don't mind I realized I can
actually figure out what the questions
are
okay they are all related to a nice cool
invention program let me take them to
the end of the talk there any questions
yeah so but if you want we can try to
see if there's questions that are
related to the current slide okay I
think there are no questions for now so
this is so this statement is a somewhat
complicated looking so I want to the
first sanity check is to check that two
implies one so it's a random variation
of the moment so I hope I convinced you
that two implies one so all right so
I've proven to I've shown you the proof
of one I have shown you that two implies
one just because to implant a true
statement that imply that two is true so
I actually have to show you that lemon
is actually true okay but glad you will
show you how to construct this matrix H
all right so let's try to prove lemon -
okay I'm going to follow us before in fu
G setting if you want to prove any
statement portfolio moves and we're
going to just do it for additional for
multiplication
all right let's do it for addition so
what does a statement look like for
addition all right remember for addition
and I will do it sorry I would like for
addition what if say I'm going to it
only for N equals two so this is what it
looks like the left-hand side looks like
this a stop F for addition is just just
slow down a second
so what's M here is just a number of
operations sorry yeah and it's the
number of bits in that input so you
think of it as operating on inside of
attacks so you're completely string yeah
okay so now we have a function it takes
n bits yes yes if I this statement holds
for X 1 to X n even if it comes thank
you so you have a polynomial any
variables you know disappointing my n
variables and I'm going to prove this
statement for n equal to 2 so called
point no mercy to robos I'm gonna prove
it for two special polynomials addition
and multiplication
okay so X is X 1 to X n yes
X is X 1 to xn yes that's correct your
annotation okay yes yes yes
so this is X 1 X 2 this for the
left-hand side looks like a f4
Changez a 1 plus a 2 f of X is X 1 plus
X 2 so I need to come with some each
such address comes this each is what I
was on the right hand side sorry for
these trivial questions but they very
much yeah yeah good yeah a good question
okay so and you want to give it a shot
okay so there is a question let me just
quickly answer the Q and a question okay
that took questions okay that's a
question about instead of si s okay this
statement is algebraic statement yeah
and I'm I want Lamar to algebraic
statements they're not about
computational assumptions so I'm going
to put questions related as is later on
this is a UH this is algebraic identity
nothing to do with assumptions okay not
in this statement and I can be naughty
reverser X the next question is it's not
true for any few yeah actually a lemon 2
is true pioneer for any thank you any
ring all right so let's try to prove our
lemma 2 okay sorry the second part of
the question okay then you have Pournami
the point on me is basically the point
Omiya okay let's try to do this for
addition okay okay perhaps perhaps when
you refer to a question about whether
the equation is true over any field you
can relate to the issue of smallness of
H as H itself has to be smaller just at
this age yeah yeah so this statement is
nothing to do small good question okay
this statement
well back in a setting we don't care
about noise for now we don't care about
security we just don't see what the
statements it's a yes or no show smoking
yeah this is really an algebraic
statement nothing to do it at this I
think of anything just algebra so if you
just so is there a sort of a trivial way
to see it without constructing age is it
I know no the statements about H right
so the statement is there as H so you
need to construct each
the statement there is this a matrix age
so we need to construct the matrix h
dilemma explicitly talks about the
scenario h maybe you can prove the
editing of the matrix h without
especially writing the other matrix h
but the question is so you're saying
even just the existence of the matrix H
is non-trivial and requires requires
proof to show yeah yeah yeah I guess you
know it's a definition of h together
with the definition of a sub F good okay
good let's pause for a second
okay so formally speaking for to be
useful you actually need this age to be
computable in point of time but let's
ignore the fact that you need to be
computable employment time whether each
Isis at all actually needs to prove what
is a sub F okay
ASA F here is still whatever a sub and
previous before yeah F applied to a 1 up
to n with some appropriate canonical
ordering for my patient so it's a
episodic point so the only thing that I
have been specified in this lemma so the
a sub F is what we find the only thing
happens pacified in dilemma is how you
construct this matrix each tissue whole
again over anything so if you just
wanted the existence of such an H right
H can depend on F X and the A's
yes you can solve a linear equation so
this is this thing that you wrote down
in lemma 2 is a linear equation you can
solve it and you can get an H so so
there exists an H but but presumably you
want something with with a nice property
I know not complete clear that a
solution to this because if you work out
the dimensions it's not quite clear that
I showed this a venous system you can
solve a linear system if a reading
system can be the case that when you try
to stop the leaving system there's it's
no solution
ok so you if you can you need at least
prove that a linear system has a
solution
true but a 1 up to a n minus X I is a
wide make a each is a wide matrix each
is going to be a square matrix for now
OHA is describing so but if you put
two of them together already you get you
get a white mini so in terms of just
kind of sanity check there might be a
solution right yeah yeah yeah it's not
obvious that there is no solution yeah
but it is also important again for the
applications that we need that it is
officially computable given the age and
the apps so it's useful to have a sense
of what a closed form expression for
issues right okay that's what you okay
but even before that you need to make
sure that the linear system S equation
has a solution okay good so I mean if
the right-hand side is zero then you
know by Counting dimension you know a
solution but the right hand side is non
zero so no not all in homogeneity in the
system as a solution even the damage is
matching yeah yeah but we want this to
hope or age so and for all axis yeah
okay so let's try to solve this nice not
so bad yeah so for addition tonight is
really easy basically you just stack two
identity matrices together so this times
this this time this sort of the right
hand side is basically if you add these
two matrices together and so
multiplication is a little bit more
interesting again okay so now you want
this time this is a1 times a2 minus x1
times x2 times okay good so what are we
going to do well going to okay well
we'll try to make this pop match up so
I'm going to take a 1 and multiplied by
a 2 over here and then now I end up you
in the bottom part so that you get the
thing on the right hand side and turns
out if you put x times X 1 times I over
here get exactly what you want so x2
times x1 gives you X 1 and X 2 and
basically the cross you get constant
actually X 1 times a 2 but it can sit
across a 2x1
and you get exactly there handsome
I think there are no questions and this
is basically tissue the construction for
our h4 addition multiplication so note
that this H actually depends on X and
the age so I claim that once you had the
addition multiplication you can add any
point for the proof of lemma 1
straightforward it's just induction for
this prove you actually need to be ok
it's not obvious that you need to
somehow glue all these matrices for each
for addition operation together to vote
for any point ok this gluing is a little
bit more non-trivial than the gluing for
the let me just say otech how do you
want to organize the rest of the talk in
terms of time because we are going to we
have a break schedule oh wait no I lost
track of time so can you tell me how
much time I have negative 2 minutes but
you know we're all friends here
oh I see okay all right sorry I lost
track of time ok let me finish
yeah that sounds that sounds all right
ok ok so right so let me just say that
basically you actually need a stronger
version of this statement which are
basically you want a statement where
you're basically relation which is a tie
by Y the matrix a and you replace I by
the gauge with matrix you get a stronger
version of this statement where you can
guarantee that each have small entries
ok and this is exactly what's going to
be useful
alright so I'm going to skip the proof
basically and this explain why you want
it to be small the reason why it is
small is useful it gives your equation
that's robust noise so what this means
is that if on the left-hand side you
have this quantity plus noise the noise
multiplied by the itch and then you get
something approximately close on your
answer so if you have a version which is
small it gives you a version of lemma 1
for approximately quality ok and the
cool is going to be and you get equation
of this Christ and the proof basically
yes before you do additional operations
you have to be a bit more careful when
you do that genius someone skip this
part so right so this equation has a
couple of application already
we have seen applications to officially
scheme risk if you look at efficacy
scheme the easter egg is basically or
evaluate the site attacks the subjects
you can after evaluation you use the
each of each matrix actually not in any
algorithm but argue the kreski so later
today you will see some on how this
equation comes up in building a be here
for you come off its nature's where the
matrix is it should accept these
different books by the way for those of
you claim bingo the tutorial dozen
counts the bingo starts all right so to
conclude our so today we have seen how
today we will see we have seen and will
continue to see how starting from
lattices you can do I cook the
computation this is the following
equation we're now eyes G and this is
guaranteed to be small and you get its
relationship okay
you won't quite see this into this store
I don't think but in some papers you
will see that instead of a minus sign
great addition sign they're basically
the same thing what we call tomato
tomahto so don't worry about the sign
also today we have seen that something
lettuces you can build a fishy for
circuits with the property that
decryption is extremely simple in fact
decryption is basically multiplied a
three back a so the caption basically is
just convenient in the product this
turns out to be very efficient scheme
with somebody captions are terribly
useful so a serial work shows that
basically you can do you can use a fishy
to sort of do some complex trapping so
if you want to build some primitive X if
you leave some primitive x4 circuits you
can it's basically sufficient to be
dispirited X for a fishy decryption
which IDs been used in the context of
our function equation of about the
collusions one key function encryption
and also in a one particular encryption
in fact uh among this was the last one
used not only that specifically uses
effect that a fishy decryption is a
proximate linear function this is out to
be a very powerful idea that we first
use in our particular protocol
encryption and tomorrow you will see
this idea being used as a starting point
for building on
simple construction obfuscation sir new
cultural obfuscation for my simple
assumptions that's going to be teen for
tomorrow the starting point and a lot of
very nice ideas that you're here
tomorrow right so today I showed you a
specific way of in some time having a
equation that stop and cost computation
into matrices and lattices on when you
say you will see a different way to
encode computation this is the soco
underlie was caught the ggh not a linear
maps you see a new way of encoding a
bunch of application and okay the
obfuscation trader facing and lock up
alpha station thus they will see a
collection of slightly different topic
you'll see connection between that this
NPC will revisit out of your solution
and we'll also look at officiating and
on Friday of course any lattice workshop
on the incomplete without some
connection to our content group all
right so let me first thank everyone and
then maybe you can unset your breaks and
I can take questions you in the Pacifica
maybe you want to say when we were with
you I want you to first look at the Q&A
and see if there's questions that you
would like to address before we before
we adjourn this session and then thank
you in the break so do I think maybe if
you see that there's questions that
could be beneficial for for much of the
audience and you can take them now if
you wish to strike so we'll post the
bündchen program I guess we should
probably just take them offline nation
LM not do is strange let me take a look
at it later to general I'm mark
inspector officially okay I'm going to
skip that question the motto is strange
let me address this lemma three strange
can you also repeat the question just so
one question was you know lemma two is
strange in the following sense if the
matrix H is not used in the scheme
anywhere how is the issues so it's
conceivable that even though it's not
used in the scheme if she's used in the
proof of security or the prove
correctness
but cooler if you look at the proof that
lemma 2 implies lemma 1 we actually use
H we use the fact that in the book of 2
times 1 we subtract that 0 times H is 0
so in the poor to them in class 1 we
object actually already used each in the
more general setting we're going to be
using the fact that you know in the
proof that lemma 2 star in fact that my
1 star which is when it is point in
class approximate version we use the
that H is small because when H is small
this implies that Cheatham this is small
small times small H is small so this is
so even though H doesn't appear in the
scheme you can still think of ways in
which you use H so the proof of them are
two interesting my use of fact that it's
small and lemma one roughly speaking is
the lemma that's used in the correctness
of the H key all right so I guess other
questions you can contact topic or you
can actually hold it if you wish you can
just go to Q&A window and and answer the
individual questions but let's take a
break let's take a 10-minute break